I don't think people are paying
attention they keep on sleeping on
LinkedIn like linkedin's been around for
20 years they're owned by Microsoft we
bought LinkedIn for 24.6 billion dollars
cash and now that platform's estimated
to be over 80 billion so they've
actually increased value of mine that
platform one of their biggest cash
purchases and one of the other
Partnerships that's going on right now
is open AI right Microsoft invested 13
billion dollars in open AI well just
like what Elon was doing with Twitter
which is why he just launched recently
his AI company he wasn't buying Twitter
to own a social platform he was really
buying it to understand that human
algorithm and be able to index all that
and how people interacted that's what
openai and Microsoft are doing with
LinkedIn and so this is that time for
everyone to be on there because
linkedin's one of the most highly
indexed SEO sites for Google out there
and they're going to be doing that same
thing with chat gbt and open AI so this
is the time to be able to make sure from
your profile to your content to your
comments that are all getting indexed
only on Google but now on open AI to re
really stand out and really take
advantage of the situation
all right believe Nation I have a
special episode of tell me why I suck
this is where I bring on Experts who are
better than me at something and they
tell me why I suck not just to beat me
up but to give me advice to improve and
help me get better to go off and change
the world today I've got Joshua B Lee in
the house who is a LinkedIn expert uh
Joshua welcome board man I have a man
excited to be here and I mean dude we're
gonna have a whole bunch of fun of uh
you know not why you suck but how do we
actually improve right here's why I did
that because when I would go uh to
YouTube events and ask for advice
people would often
hedge their opinion
yeah that's like it might happen yeah
lots of things to say but but they don't
know you and so they they hedge and so I
said now tell me why I suck you know
like give me everything tell me what
because I want to get better right and
it's not that I suck as a human I just
suck at the thing I suck at a skill so
to help me get better so so Josh and I
met at an event and we sat across from
each other and that just left this Vibe
love the story love the Mohawk jealous
of the hair it's great and uh I said
LinkedIn man I used to be hardcore
LinkedIn back in the day where they
would track your country like how many
what what rank you were in your country
I was like top 500 in Canada I don't
know how long ago that was that was that
was like OG LinkedIn so it might be
tough 500 in Canada not even being on
there so it's you know it it was my
first social platform yeah I think it's
one of the longest running man I mean
it's 20 years old I mean as of this year
is it really wow so there's no other
social platform that's been running as
long as LinkedIn
so it was my first and then I created a
bunch of stuff on there I don't know
what we're doing on it right now to be
honest I'm I'm I probably extra suck on
LinkedIn so I'm very excited to have you
dive in dissect and teach me what I need
to do is there anything you want to tell
my audience about you you know
highlights before we jump in yeah I mean
like look you know the reason why we
kind of go through I mean and Evan I'll
give everyone a kind of brief background
of my history right like I started my
first company back in 2002 2003
um in the online advertising space one
of my first clients one of those
companies that most people forgot about
myspace so you know been doing it for a
bit right I mean I actually helped
Myspace develop one of the first social
media ads to monetize their traffic I've
gone through and monetized
man billions of Revenue on online being
able to go through and I think I've had
over 35 trillion online Impressions
across my own servers and one of the
biggest things that I learned throughout
that entire process was there's actually
a huge difference actually traffic and
actually true engagement and I think
that's the biggest thing right after
this is my 16th company running standout
Authority and I went through a reset in
my life about nine years ago where I'm
outside looking in I was going through
and it was like
you know what I perception was Josh is
doing very well you know he because
based on what people look at right
success is based on monetary value I was
running multiple companies six seven
eight figures but I was unhappy because
it was all about chasing the money and
so that's where standard Authority was
born once I went through a reset walked
away from everything and really started
over was how do I actually educate
Inspire and draw people in on a platform
that most people don't understand how do
I actually understand that human
algorithm not just chasing the LinkedIn
algorithm or the Facebook or the YouTube
or whatever that is and that's the one
that stands the test of time so that's
kind of why we're here today and you
know we'll share a little bit about how
to be able to leverage that and not have
to shift and understand the next hacker
trick every six months every time the
algorithm change and use something that
will really benefit everyone all right
well let's dive in I don't know if you
want to pull up my accounts or whatever
you want to do tell me why I suck Josh
let's go
linkedin's a Power Platform right I
don't think people are paying attention
they keep on sleeping on LinkedIn like
even you brother I mean like these days
like linkedin's been around for 20 years
they're owned by Microsoft right so
Microsoft and most people don't realize
they bought LinkedIn for 24.6 billion
dollars cash and now that platform's
estimated to be over 80 billion so
they've actually increased value of mine
that platform one of their biggest cash
purchases until Activision that's
happening now right that's kind of going
through as a resulting a massive win for
them and one of the other Partnerships
that's going on right now is open AI
right Microsoft invested 13 billion
dollars in open AI well just like what
Elon was doing with Twitter which is why
he just launched recently his AI company
he wasn't buying Twitter to own a social
platform he was truly buying it to
understand that human algorithm and be
able to index all that and how people
interacted
that's what openai and Microsoft are
doing with LinkedIn and so this is that
time for everyone to be on there because
linkedin's one of the most highly
indexed SEO sites for Google out there
and they're going to be doing that same
thing with chat gbt and open AI so this
is the time to be able to make sure from
your profile to your content to your
comments that are all getting indexed
not only on Google but now on open AI to
really stand out and really take
advantage of the situation we're going
to start with your profile and then go
from there you cool with that yeah yeah
let's go built to serve is my my book
yeah and the last time we did anything
on LinkedIn I think was really around
built to serve yeah uh which would have
been two or three years ago as like a
major campaign or focused effort and I
think since then it's just been I don't
know whatever we post on Instagram or
YouTube or whatever it's it's always
been the second year there's never been
a primary since then it hasn't been a
primary LinkedIn strategy so no and
that's that whole piece right and it all
starts with your profile because I mean
the biggest thing when you're doing the
right way right being able to really
engage with people if you draw your
audience in and you don't have that
personal brand to be able to convert on
the other side you're wasting your time
putting out a whole bunch of content for
content's sake I mean Evan I always say
these days too like content's not King
anymore quality is Queen right being
able to put out quality content because
even before there was so much content
out there now we add AI in there dude
everyone's just throwing up content so
like you want to make sure that quality
of content not only is good but at the
same time it goes back to a profile that
people go oh man that's who I want to
connect with because Evan I look on here
the first thing I see is Speaker author
introvert Mission solve world's number
one problem all that's great but that's
about you it's not customer facing
forward
so and one thing too is the emojis on
your on your speaker on your title
they break the algorithm so you're not
showing up in search results
I want people to find you I don't want
you always having to go out and have you
to go look for your clients and your
audience I want them to be able to find
you and the more times that you show up
and not only LinkedIn results but Google
it's gonna be better for you okay I'm
taking notes cutting up the Emojis well
we start off with as well too with all
of our clients and I mean dude I've been
blessed right a lot of our friends I've
been able to work with over the years
people that I used to you know read
their books on how to be able to start
my own companies are now people that I
consider clients and good friends and so
even with that like we look at it going
the first for your title should be the
XYZ statement I help X to achieve why so
they can have or you know go through a z
right I hope X identifies your target
audience right this is who we want to be
able to serve right we want to be
polarizing with this so people that we
want to draw in and there's people that
we don't
right so I help X to achieve y most
people you know you're you're a
brilliant marketer what do most
marketers do they sell on a service they
provide right so let me ask you this
okay I've got I've got two options here
yeah the one is brand and that's what I
mostly do on YouTube it's it's I'm Gonna
Change the World it's how do we impact
every human trying to solve the world's
biggest problem that's that's what
YouTube has been about right and to be
honest I think that's what all of my all
of my social has been about it's never
been trying to get customers directly we
would do that through ads and through uh
email so it's all been forward-facing
now I could you know like the things
that we sell uh I wouldn't do that as a
YouTube strategy but like the things
that we sell uh my movement makers
program The Mastermind that I've got uh
the book I think was a little effort to
do that but it's not really built to
serve it's not the main focus at the
moment should I have a separate LinkedIn
strategy that's more targeted towards
helping thought leaders build their
movement I personally would right now
like they look at okay great he's a
speaker he's an author and invert like
there's a lot of people that have that
same title right most people go in they
go I'm the CEO of it doesn't stand now
when there's searching for someone like
oh that's me I'm looking for that oh I
would like that result right because
again the long run we all make decisions
based on some emotional connection to
love or hate of some degree and so
that's kind of why we have that XYZ
statement I help X the ideal client to
do the service so they have an outcome
right the real result of why everyone
usually wants to work with someone
follow something whatever it might be
able to do and that's kind of why we use
that and then we'll put speaker author
you know introvert Force after that but
we want that first thing to be able to
grab someone's attention it's like a
you know it's like the first line of an
email for me I would make some of those
adjustments and really be able to kind
of adjust that to be able to draw that
audience so you're specifically grind
because the audience on LinkedIn
you're you're looking at a higher
elevated audience right so average
income on LinkedIn is around 120 000 a
year most people 50 or more people on
LinkedIn have a college of your higher
so you have an educated audience and
then four out of five people on the
platform are still business decision
makers so you have an audience that has
the you know income
knowledge and power to buy right so
that's why there's a lot of opportunity
there to be able to build that audience
now I don't want you to think about
audiences to be able to buy and clients
right like I want to help you build
Advocates first
and allow that byprod to become clients
because that's the biggest problem with
like that messaging people go all the
time hey Evan man I see you're wearing a
shirt me too
let's connect you're like
the hell are you just getting spammed
all the time so that's where we're
trying to be able to shift here is who's
reaching out to and what it's much more
sales and marketing approach instead of
brand correct but I mean we look at a
personal brand perspective you want to
have that in the front part but these
are your Brands and we will continue to
be able to go in there so it's a mixture
of both right marketing and brand being
able to put into one
okay does that help yeah yeah I bet
totally doable I mean I'm known for a
lot of different things uh and we're
taking our YouTube Instagram
Etc strategy and putting it here and you
know I suck so let's go so here's the
whole thing too right like I want to be
able to look at their headline what's
kind of going on so if we pull up
you know my profile here being able to
look at it really quickly
like this is your opportunity you know
to be able to actually have a call to
action talk about what's going on give
it a little bit more information you've
got a great picture on yours but I want
to be able to actually show what you do
what you stand for in some of those
different aspects right so this is an
opportunity for you to be able to go in
rather than just having
two pictures of you kind of going
through I'd like to be able to have
something a little bit more of why we
use these as Billboards so when we have
events we have different things coming
up we'll swap that out we don't just
leave it static as well so we're always
constantly adjusting that to be able to
show what we're talking about what we're
doing and we have one slide if we don't
have an event coming up we don't have
something new that's happening right now
then we kind of go back to that slide I
just showed you there
okay so some of those things that I want
you to be able to look at now you've
already got Creator mode on which is
great now the hashtags that you guys
have Associated right now is author
believe YouTuber entrepreneur
entrepreneurship not bad it's who you
are it's what you do are you talking
about being an author are you talking
about believe I might change belief
because I doubt there's many people
following belief
you might want to be able to go in but
like what are you actually creating
content because what linkedin's looking
for
is for to make sure that these five
hashtags that you're creating content on
at least match on a on a consistent
basis because they've recently changed
the hour and make sure that they're not
allowing they don't want YouTube videos
or videos of Hey a cat hanging in there
right that are viral they're actually
decreasing the visibility on those and
making sure that what you talk about as
your hashtags a line that you're adding
value each time with your content so
that's where I would make sure like
whatever your content whatever your
content pillars are make sure they're
aligned with that so you're kind of
going through to be able to make sure it
kind of goes through putting now the
like sales and marketing hat on instead
of like General brand my main offering I
guess is my movement makers program we
train people to be thought leaders and
then there's a mastermind up from that
if people want to join so be like
thought leader speaker influencer
YouTuber coach that kind of stuff is
hashtags yeah exactly so that's what I
want you to kind of think about and you
can go through
so we can kind of go in look at hashtag
believe
twelve thousand followers so that's not
a huge following right being able to go
through we usually try to be able to
have you know there's almost one billion
people on LinkedIn right now so we're
always trying to be able to look for we
might have some that are very specific
like if I want to actually be Evan
Carmichael that's fine we'll do that I
want that to be tight but at the same
time I want the other ones to have a
much higher visibility like hashtag
marketing I think has nine you know nine
million people following it right or or
more than 90 million people following it
so because those people that follow
those hashtags and when you have those
hashtags Associated your content will
now show up allowing you to draw in more
people to your view visibility you know
just like any other platform so you know
what we're looking at being able to go
through that's kind of the hashtag
aspect of it so you've got the Creator
mode on the next thing I would say Evan
this is your ability to be able to go in
and yes again branding media to go
through but we usually look at this as a
first person right not Evan this looks
like your PR guy wrote this about you
this is your profile this is you going
through I would rather use speak from a
first person perspective rather than
speaking from a third person's
perspective being able to talk about
your bio and what we kind of go through
and do is as I look at your bio it's
great being able to go through and
you've covered all the bases right like
most people missed that this is not an
area that you suck you've done this
really well all I would do is switch
this to a first person
great so you've done that well some of
the other pieces when we look at when we
talk about profile brother it's looking
here your experience right author
founder content creator now you didn't
start your do you start was your first
career started in 2008 are they the only
companies that you've ever been
associated with
and no they're not that you sold a
massive company years ago right
yeah that was before is that I don't
know if that's on there it's not okay
but that's what I'm saying right like I
want to be able to understand like
people go through and they start like oh
I'm the CEO of standard Authority I
wasn't born that way right I've had
other jobs I want you to be
inspirational to others like if you go
to my profile the first job that I show
on there I was a server at Chili's
people go why would you have that on
there okay it allows connection allows
commonality you know any message like it
like oh my God Josh you worked at
Chili's me too now we have commonality
now we can actually start a conversation
build a relationship and create
opportunity and so we kind of go through
we start putting all those pieces in to
really be able to show someone else that
you know whoever you started they had
that opportunity to be able to be the
next Evan as well too because you
started where you started somewhere
where they were too and these are all
indexable points right we want to be
able to show you more in the algorithm
so the more points that we actually hit
on there and add value to the more
opportunity you're going to show up when
people are searching for you
started my company 20 years ago holy cow
let's go
and that's great right and you've done a
good job of being able to go through so
I'm glad you got this you know being
able to go through you you've added and
this is what you want to make sure
everyone needs to be able to make sure
that you're adding enough information
here on the different aspects of the
different companies yeah I can tweak
those two I mean we I haven't looked at
that in years so yeah so I'm sure you
have I mean there's definitely ways to
be able to tweak it to be able to go in
add it's great to be able to right here
like this is a broken link that's not
actually going through so it's actually
the picture should show up here I would
go through and make sure you adjust the
links should I have
author for every book that I've created
so there's ways to be able to do it
let's jump over here to my profile
and I want to show you some sections
that we're missing right being able to
go through so featured section you want
me to have a feature section I do
right it's like a news headline we try
to go be able to be able to go through
and change so like featured sections I
have my newsletter I have a post that
recently did really well because I'm
talking about AI I have other ones that
actually tell about my story it allows
me to be able to go through I was
featured in an article right I go
through if we actually go through all
the featured items you'll actually find
different podcasts that are associated
with what it allows me to be able to do
is not only be able to see some of the
ways that I've been featured I want them
to be able to see
but also I have testimonials as well on
here as well so they can actually hear
other people talking about me
right I'll actually have podcasts on
here as well right so people can
actually hear my voice
so again what we're trying to be able to
do is build that relationship so we go
through here and we'll change these out
all the time to be able to actually make
sure whatever actually is is what we
want to be at top view right now that's
not a link to go to sign up and hire you
that's still just kind of branding but
inside of the inside of your Niche yep
all branding yeah okay again I've never
sell right like what I want to do is I
want to educate Inspire and draw my
audience to a point that they are
understand they have an issue and then
reaching out to me to be able to solve
it right like I don't want to be that
guy sending out a thousand messages
hoping to get the one sale when all in
essence all I'm doing is pissing off 999
people that's what most people do on
LinkedIn it's exhausting right so that's
where we start really being able to back
this up being able to go through and
make sure our profile as you see here
right like hey there I'm Joshua B Lee
you might know me as the doping deer
LinkedIn right like I'm going through
here to be able to really tell a story
of who I was where I've been where I'm
at now and where I'm going
and so emojis in the about section is
fine it's not interesting about section
or five right being able to go through
same thing right we talk about my
experience if we went through
I mean I got 18 experiences on here
so these are those things I really want
you to be able to go through and show
all the different companies you know
I've started 16 companies so I've got my
companies in here as you see like I've
got here's my standard Authority
experience right being able to go
through I've got that link right on here
to be able to go through I've got a link
to one of my websites I've got links to
my articles right on entrepreneur
Maverick 1000 right entrepreneur all
these other things I try to be able to
add and we can keep on going down and
down and down all the way to Chili's
I wasn't lying it's really on there
so that's where I want everyone to kind
of think about right like what's that
career Journey what's that career story
that you can actually inspire others
with a couple other things that I want
you to be able to think about that
aren't on your profile
I've even put my high school
I know you ever Collins can cannot it's
amazing LinkedIn will connect other
people saying hey Evan goes went to your
high school do you want to connect right
okay um licensing certifications if you
have them it's great to be able to again
all we're doing is padding your brand
right letting people know what's going
on what you've done and how to be able
to go through it now you're talking
about podcasts right so we've got
different projects that I'm working on
or I have been working on
volunteering huge right like so I'm the
resident Spider-Man at Dell Children's
Hospital here in Austin Texas right so
you know I'm always trying to be spandex
ready but I mean like I want people to
understand like I'm not just all
business right I want them to see what I
do on the sides and how I give back to
my community
all these things you have all these
different profile sections Evan from
education position career break you know
licenses projects courses
recommendations test scores languages or
I mean causes different things that
you're associated with being able to
make sure
you'll basically fill it as much as
possible from those options exactly and
this is where the Publications right so
I want any articles any podcasts here so
when this goes live I'm going to be
putting this link to this YouTube up on
here as well too every single podcast
I've ever done
associated with is now on my LinkedIn
you have no oh my gosh you know how many
there are that was insane but I'm sure
you have someone on your team to be able
to help you support you do that yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay wow but think
about that right the indexing SEO the
mod score is 100 out of 100 so all this
gets indexed higher on Google for you to
be found more
and then are you putting a description
for each one I guess yeah yeah
okay basically I mean we're not going
deep man I mean like some of these are a
little bit longer most of these some of
these are descriptions are just the ones
that I grabbed off of their podcast that
I did yeah yeah
you know honors and awards right
organizations interests all these things
you know are really really important for
you to do now the one thing I want to
talk to you about as well the last piece
on your profile before we jump the next
thing
is your skills
you can adjust these right so like
mine's LinkedIn marketing online
marketing entrepreneurship right you can
go through I've got a hundred skills on
there these are where you're going to be
found for most on LinkedIn if these are
your top three you can hit that little
button right there and I want you to be
able to go through and we can actually
reorder
and I can move the top three that I want
to be found for what are the three
things that I want to be known for and
found for on LinkedIn and I can drag
them around wherever I want
okay so for years when we go back to
your profile
what are my skills I have no idea this
will be fun what are my skills you've
got entrepreneurship online advertising
and SEO is that what you want to be
known for when people search so those
are the top three categories you want to
be found in I can move it around and if
you don't right like you've got 50 other
skills on here let's say that one of the
one of these things aren't on there like
you want to be YouTube Star right you
you want that to be a skill you can
actually type that in LinkedIn marketing
wasn't a skill on there until I typed it
in okay I don't think I ever figured out
any I think it's just people endorsed me
so I just approved them what's the
weirdest skill on that list I got 50
skills apparently out of that I've had
some weird ones too and I'm just like
okay this person just gave me this one
so let's see here you got small business
marketing small business online
marketing let's go to the bottom of the
list here and see what happens yeah yeah
okay
business planning lead gen web Market
digital kind of normal strategy internet
strategy web Analytics
online reputation
look at this list makes me feel like I
don't suck
Smo
what is that
I don't even know I just want to ask you
I'm like what's Smo
46 people think I'm good at it for some
reason okay great
I'm like smso Google webmaster tools is
the is the least that you have the most
but again I mean like none of this is
like crazy the only one I'm like I don't
know what Smo is
so it's just one of those things man I
mean like bring the one that you want
known for the most up to the top
it's probably small and medium
organizations like smbs yeah
so you've got small small business
marketing now smbs you can put drive
that up right bring it to the top
because that's where you'll get indoors
for the most and the more endorsements
you get the way the heavier that weighs
on your profile the more times when
people are searching for that the more
you'll show up yeah oh no I think that's
what what smos is small medium
organizations
okay well if you and I don't know what
it is I don't know how anyone else knows
what it is 46 people or they just
randomly click endorse you and I have
been running companies for 20 years and
we were still like what's an Smo
[Laughter]
other thing dude you have 3.2 million
followers and subscribers on YouTube
right I know you're adding value all the
time
are they following you on on LinkedIn
and two the last recommendation you got
was in 2021 I know you've been kicking
ass since 2021 right so this is what I
really love about recommendations on
LinkedIn they stand the test of time
right I can go back and I know one of my
first recommendations happened in 2007
right so unlike where someone goes hey
can you give me I'm going for a new job
or I'm doing this can can I put you down
as a referral right make a call yeah
Evan's amazing Great Click out of sight
out of mind LinkedIn recommendation
stand that has the time and because
they've already been verified by
LinkedIn you can actually screenshot
these and use them on your own websites
if you want to for marketing go out
there you can actually go through I can
go in and recommend but you can also ask
for recommendations as well so like
everyone watching right like if you're
watching and you've gotten awesome
advice from Evan go on his LinkedIn
profile right offer a recommendation
form because again this will help you
and being able to go through and being
able to feature more people on your
profile
so that's your profile does that make
sense basic stuff you've done a really
good job overall you don't suck your
slight adjustments what was that thing
at the bottom interest to set interests
the only person that you like is Tony
Robbins that I like yeah you're
following Tony Robbins as a top voice oh
okay wow this again is alignment right
so this is people like people that
follow Tony Robbins they're like oh Evan
follows Tony Robbins so do you do you
want to follow him right going through
so go through like I'll have
my bottom right I've got lots of
different voices that I follow to be
able to go through and align myself with
other audiences
so from the CEO of LinkedIn lots of
different people that I follow that are
top voices on LinkedIn being able to go
through Assad that Association but at
the same point right I have companies
that I follow groups that I'm a part of
newsletters that I'm associated with
schools all this is indexed right so the
more information like if you have
Associated and go through fill it in if
there's an opportunity to fill it in
fill it in because all it's going to do
is index you higher in the algorithm and
allow you to be found more and then drop
your audience to you rather than you
having to go find them
we talked about your profile let's go on
to your content
now this is my BYU suck
good yeah probably it's not the content
it's just how it's being put out right
yeah it's it it's again it looks like
you're cut copying pacing this this
posting this to post right not being
able to go in there now here's the
biggest thing right there's almost one
billion people on LinkedIn
out of that billion people that are act
that are LinkedIn users only about
three million actually posts on a
regular basis but there's over nine
billion content Impressions weekly so
those three million people are getting
access to nine billion content
Impressions so there's a lot of organic
traffic that most people aren't taking
advantage of and so like with you having
40 000 followers going on here you
should be getting more engagement in
this but some of it's because of the
post right one anytime you link off site
even if it's YouTube
you're going to be able to go They're
Gonna ding you right know a social
website wants you the linking off-site
right so being able to go through there
hashtags are important on LinkedIn right
you don't have any hashtags on here so
what we want to be able to see too is
you wanted the magic number they made a
whole song about it years ago three is
the magic number
okay right so being able to happen see
if one of those five hashtags that you
have associated with your your creator
mode on LinkedIn Associates with that
content right being able to go through
you get a boost being able to go through
but again free pdf summaries for YouTube
videos it's just being okay that's a
fact
but we're not kind of going and sell
story I use when I create content on
LinkedIn I use the 10 2070 method of
creating content have you heard of that
one before
nope
so 10 personal right people connect with
other people right it's it's like I call
my door to the couch mentality come here
to me knocking on the door going hey I'm
Josh you know what's you and I are
hanging on the couch or hanging out a
genius right being able to go through we
had that commonality being we go through
but like it's not Facebook I don't need
to know when your kids are going to
school but I need to know you have them
right so like what's that 10 personal
about you that people can have that
commonality and bond to people think
they know you Evan kerm and go oh Evan's
like me right so 10 of your content
needs to be personal
20 of it should talk about your company
but not about what you can do for
someone what you've done for someone
else right we want to be storytellers
we want to be able to go and we only do
it 20 of the time because we don't want
to be that guy right we don't even like
oh there there's Josh again that dude
never shuts up about LinkedIn void avoid
avoid most people are on LinkedIn are
that guy they're on the platform talking
about themselves talk about their
business all the time it's exhausting so
we only do that about 20 times 70 other
add value we want to be an aggregator of
value so the content that we're putting
on LinkedIn we want to be educating and
inspiring our audience to be able to to
really
change the world right what you want to
be able to do solving the world's
biggest problems right how are you doing
that are you adding that content being
able to go through there so we want to
make sure you have up to 3 000
characters which is crazy to be able to
do a post
I wouldn't suggest that but the biggest
thing that you want to be able to do is
get people to click more right so we
can't see it on yours right now but if I
went into another post
I see there's we're going in here
none of these you have one-liners and
people going into yeah watching videos
are kind of going through but
we don't have enough content to be able
to have a more button here that makes
people going that actually weighs more
because what they're looking for is
dwell time
right not only watching your video but
are they reading your content
to be able to go in so that more button
shows more dwell time love this picture
by the way you need to have it you know
behind you at all times
yep it's there it's right there and then
you know with some of these things so on
LinkedIn
you've got a free pdf going in there but
you didn't even go through and load this
up as a PDF
a PDF would allow you to be able to do
this in a carousel mode right being able
to go through and actually allow someone
to be able to scroll through and be able
to see it so what you want to be able to
do instead of having loading pictures
like this
you want to upload it as a PDF on
LinkedIn
okay
so I can kind of show you here so we're
starting a post right being able to go
in
you go here and then we've got create a
poll add a document right this is where
you can add a PDF and when you add it as
a PDF it will actually create a carousel
style post and we're actually seeing
great visibility on those right now
okay
so those that kind of post I mean I
guess it comes back to the very first
thing that we talked about profiling a
Joe dispenza or Tony Robbins whoever is
part of my much bigger brand yeah but
it's not inside of the helping people
become thought leaders spread your
message to the world correct so we want
to be able to make sure we ship that
right how do you actually go through not
just profiling people but how do you
actually give them actionable advice on
a regular basis linkedin's looking at
that and actually promoting that content
more
well I would this is all personal
development yeah so it would be it would
like it would be cut under the new
strategy yeah yeah I would be I would
definitely adjust it right being able to
go through adding those hashtags being
able to go through let's look at the
comments
so you have people coming on here
do you have anyone on your team engaging
with those people
well that doesn't look like it yeah I
don't I but
maybe I gotta look into that but I hear
you yes like if we don't we shouldn't if
you don't you should right so this is
some of those things right so you do
have some people going here that was
this probably earlier I just want to
make sure that's always happening right
someone's being able to go through so
you are yeah I apologize we were looking
at that first one it's just very new the
first hour is critical
right so this is a post is a day old
what you want to be able to do in that
first 60 to 90 minutes LinkedIn looks
are you engaging back with your audience
right being able to go through when a
post goes live so that actually does
increase in visibility kind of going
through
Just for information okay
um I would say on your on your videos
here it's a great video
but you and I both know a lot of people
especially on LinkedIn we need the
captions LinkedIn does have Auto
captions on there they can actually add
it to be able to go through if you're
not building it always put your captions
on your video especially on LinkedIn and
um transcript yeah yeah you can upload a
transcript everything
so it's really really easy to be able to
go through and do you recommend that
I do okay yeah 100 being able to go
through so like that's just some of
those pieces right like in we're looking
at going through
what you want to do is think about this
too one post a day it's LinkedIn is not
a platform to be able to go through and
add a ton of posts on a regular basis
you're doing pretty well on being able
to do it a post on a daily basis right
so you're doing great there being able
to look at so these are some of those
pieces Evan that I look at right we look
to your profile your content I would add
you know add a little bit more
description adjust the content to be
able to fit for that audience and then
add Auto captions on there and be able
to upload the transcript
but other than that
you know you've done a fairly good job
of posting on a consistent basis being
able to go through
the one thing that I think you're
missing we talked about this already was
the newsletter
right you don't have a newsletter on
LinkedIn right now and I I personally
would highly recommend you being able to
do that because you told me when we were
one of your goals is to be able to get
to from 3.2 million to what 65 million
that'd be great 35 is the goal but it's
fine we'll take 65. maybe I'm thinking
too small Josh you know maybe
35 million subscribers and you said one
of the biggest ways that you get
engagement is through email so what I
love about LinkedIn
is their LinkedIn newsletters right now
they have 100 deliverability when
they're going through so is this part of
my content or this is a whole new
different thing if you already have a
newsletter yeah all you have to do is
upload it and be able to go into
newsletters right so let me pull up my
newsletters here real quick just so you
can kind of see
as I've got mine so very quick dopamine
dose I've got 15 000 subscribers I share
weekly basis being able to go through
and you know this is this is something
we created specifically for LinkedIn
it's a little bit different but I have a
lot of clients that we go through and
they're creating a newsletter that is
they already do for their clients and
they're just repurposing and putting it
on here right one of the things we have
to do we have clients that have podcasts
have YouTube channels where they'll go
through and they'll actually build a
newsletter specifically to summarize
what the month looked like what the last
week looked like here's the top YouTube
videos that we were going through here's
my top podcast over the last month
really being able to summarize it
because now not only are they going to
get a notification on LinkedIn but
they're also going to get an email and
they're in their inbox from LinkedIn 100
deliverability actually talking about
that newsletter and newsletters at part
of content or that's a different section
on LinkedIn it is part of content but
what you want to think of like so I do
newsletters every Tuesday right so mine
things letter goes out every Tuesday and
I have a post Monday Wednesday Thursday
Friday so that's I don't do two posts a
day because I LinkedIn newsletter post
is still a post we don't want to double
up we only want to do one post a day
because if you do two posts in a day
Evan that second post needs 10 times the
engagement to get the same visibility so
if your first post that day got five
likes and five comments now you need to
get 50 likes and 50 comments to get the
same a thousand views that you got on
the first one right you're working
harder not smarter okay so you'll
actually to create your newsletter hit
right article
and then up here in the top right hand
corner is where it will say create your
newsletter mine's already here right so
for a news newsletter I can actually
change the individual article but I say
create your first newsletter you want to
have uploaded images being able to go
through and this is the beautiful thing
right we can create these newsletters
images videos slides links Snippets
right being able to go through we can
create the newsletter how people digest
information some people love to read the
book other people wait for the audio and
then we got the others that wait for the
movie to come out
so you can actually go through there and
it's got great integration with
different podcasts and YouTube websites
to really integrate the video very very
well
so that's how I would recommend as
you're kind of going through here that's
one of the pieces that you're missing
brother is really being able to make
sure
that we've got that newsletter and
taking another opportunity to be able to
get into everyone's inbox with your
content information and be able to
Leverage
your YouTube and be able to start
bringing in more subscribers and
allowing LinkedIn to be able to do that
for you very passively what do you think
I mean like those are some of the basics
going through that's just your profile
and talking about content and what
you're missing right now and of course
we could go through strategies all kind
of other stuff on how to be able to
actually build relationships but you
know I want us you know what are your
thoughts so far makes a lot of sense I
thought I would suck harder than
apparently I do or you're being kind the
biggest strategic shift is saying hey
this isn't this isn't the believe
message for the world this is a thought
leader message for a sub a sub of a sub
segment of who I who my audience is
correct and that's a that's the best way
to be able to do it right you've got
some articles in here
let's see the last article you did was
in 2019 right that is an article a post
as well yeah it's an article you did in
2019 so all these are integrated right
like if you've got articles that are
going back in you can start sharing
these right like I get views on my
articles I got a a comment and some
engagement on an article that I wrote
four years ago on LinkedIn they don't
lose right they stay in the algorithm
that's the beautiful thing content all
that content LinkedIn because it's so
highly indexed not only on LinkedIn but
on on Google as well you don't lose it
overnight right like Twitter the post is
gone in a couple hours yeah with this
just like in YouTube it lives on forever
YouTube's a search engine interest is
the search engine LinkedIn is a search
engine right like we kind of go through
we do an article like we'll go through
and not only put the article out there
but we'll actually then share that link
to that article and pin it on Pinterest
okay do we even get that double
indexable and the search engine there's
lots of different ways to be able to go
in man but like articles being able to
go through if you have articles on your
on your website
go through repurpose them on here you're
not looking at that Ding because again
the Moz score is 100 out of 100 on
LinkedIn how they index on Google so
like you're not you can actually
repurpose the exact same content and
actually get better visibility for it on
LinkedIn than on your own website
okay but yeah man I mean that's that's
the biggest things that I'm seeing right
now as we kind of go through look at
your profile
I would just say that we just need to be
able to have more of you show up we need
to be able to put more of who you are
where you've been and what you're doing
and what you're where you're going on
your profile really flush that out on
your content let's be able to go a
little bit more intentional right making
sure that we're actually putting a
little bit more content in there with
the hashtags and then when you're
actually posting those videos making
sure that they have the captions on
there and I mean once you start doing
that
that's great to be able to start but
there's also you know being able to pay
attention we can see on LinkedIn Evan
everyone that engages in our content we
can actually with one of the few
profiles
um platforms I should say that I can see
every single person that looks at my
profile right being able to go through
there so you talked about
I'll get this last little tip and then
you know we can kind of go wherever you
like man but everyone hates cold calling
code even right unless you just love to
be able to analyze how people are doing
things right most of us we get the call
if it someone doesn't say hello in two
seconds we hang up we're like
I don't know this number and that's the
biggest problem with LinkedIn you know
people are always spamming being
innovative
we want to be intentional on how we
actually do LinkedIn I'm not just going
to put content out there and hope that
my the someone finds I'm not going to
put it out there go okay
are they coming what's going on I want
to be able to draw my audience in so
engaging with people that engage with
you right being able to acknowledge the
people that look at your profile right
reaching out to them being able to start
a relationship conversation people that
engage if you want to be able to draw
your audience in LinkedIn sales
Navigator awesome way to be able to do
it most marketers go in there and
they're like hey I see you're in
marketing let's connect right and then
they pitch you
the average person on LinkedIn gets less
than one percent engagement
so what we use LinkedIn so is now we're
going to be able to do is there's a
feature on there that allows us to be
able to see the ideal audience that
we're looking at
who is actually posted on LinkedIn in
the last 30 days now I can be
intentional on how I'm actually building
relationships I can go in like if I want
to get your attention Evan I'll like
your post I'll comment on it and then
I'm going to reach out and say hey Evan
I saw your recent post on X and I just
want to reach out and say thank you you
know too often don't appreciate these
things I'd love to be able to understand
a little bit more love to be able to
connect with you right being able to
appreciate people for things they take
for granted because most of us are on
this pattern of like comment share post
like comment share post
and we create a stop gap of appreciation
that we forget to be able to appreciate
those things that we do from looking at
a post engaging on a post looking at
someone's profile or posting content it
creates opportunity to be able to have a
conversation and build that relationship
and create new opportunities especially
on LinkedIn so what would you recommend
for me I mean I I can't keep up with all
the comments on any of my platforms
right so people on my team will help and
they handle kind of first first line of
if they're saying hey I've been great
post they respond you know yeah if it's
negative or it's a suggestion or it's an
opportunity then they send it to me yeah
uh we're doing zero you know Outreach uh
and I don't know if that even makes
sense as a as a team you know like
coming from my account to say hey it's
Susan on Evan's team that was a great
post you made does that make sense or is
there an easy way to do it or what do
you recommend well and so we kind of go
through right we allow everyone to be
able to take their own Journey so when
we were working when I was because I
helped Dan Sullivan create his first
link all right and we were reaching out
for on his behalf or strategic coach
when we were trying to be able to do
that we were identifying that audience
right and being able to go through and
acknowledge people right it's amazing we
forget sometimes as you and I have been
doing this 20 years Dan's been doing
even longer right and some of these
people that are out there like to
appreciate these people that have made
us who we are right being able to go
through I'll show you how we actually
kind of go
and actually build and connect with our
audience and to be able to make it in a
Real Fashion and so this is what we do
with our clients this is what we kind of
go in so
let me pull this document up here real
quick and I'll kind of show you because
it's it's important to see how we're
treating people like a human being right
I'm just doing the things that my mother
taught me how to be able to treat other
human beings we're just doing it online
right starting with appreciation hey I
just want to reach out and say thank you
thank you Chris a stop Gap in their
pattern thank you for engaging my
content thank you for engaging looking
at my profile or thank you for posting
great content right being able to go
through and be intentional about that
with the right people creates massive
advocacy and it's amazing what that
actually happens when you actually
connect with
and it's big when someone like you or I
or someone else does that
that's okay with some team yeah
yeah okay and so we kind of go through
to be able to say this right the people
appreciate being appreciated right it's
it's those things that kind of go
through so like with Dan right hey Mash
I just want to reach out and say thank
you for liking our post right we're
allowing them to take their enjoy we're
saying our post unan Howe and following
C2 coach again an Inception to be able
to go through being able to start a
conversation around he's like wow man
thank you so much you know I appreciate
you being able to go through there now
this is the biggest thing most will
pitch as soon as they kind of go through
my mother always taught me to be able to
to give someone a competent when I meet
them right love your picture cool hat
cool dog whatever it is on LinkedIn
and I appreciation B is an endorsement
right to give someone a compliment so we
go through and endorse people go how can
you endorse someone if you don't know
that
my house my kids man it's it's nice to
be nice right that's our first rule in
our house
so when we're actually kind of going
through there we're endorsing someone to
be able to go through they usually go
back through and endorse again this
allows them to be rough up the
conversation ask a very
qualifying question to understand where
they're at again making it about them
we're giving little hits of dopamine to
be able to put them in a flow state of
conversation and then be able to provide
value based on what we've done and so
this is what we're constantly doing with
our clients
to be able to go through and have these
little mini conversations and this
happened in seven days
so that's what we're doing for our
clients and to really be able to make
sure that
we're having real conversations no
matter if it's the team whatever who was
representing to be able to go through we
appreciate we we complement we ask about
them and we provide value right and so
like that question I show you with Dan
you consider yourself an entrepreneur or
a business owner with an entrepreneurial
mindset we always ask questions that are
mindset oriented not do you make a
million dollars
is there yes or no questions they stop
and most weren't going to answer those
that question we use there we also use
with Joe as well like it worked really
well because it allows us to understand
where someone is and how they think and
also give us that silent answer C I work
for somebody else
and based on that response there
entrepreneur early on the career okay we
were able to provide a PDF starter kit
to be able to get going business owner
without no mindset okay they've been a
little bit farther let's jump on a call
with my team or I work for somebody else
hey I'd love to be able to offer you the
book who not how this is we actually did
that with Dan and when Ben Hardy was
relaunching with Dan right BDA go
through and offer that free always
leaving without you and that's how we
make Advocates and that's what we do on
LinkedIn to really stand out compared to
most people on the platform that Halbert
has add a whole bunch more stuff on your
blade well no I mean that that just
becomes team or service or figuring that
part out because I I would not be
reaching at the people on LinkedIn but
yeah and any message that comes you know
from me but it's not me would have to
say who like correct I never leave a
comment that says my name if it's not me
so they always put like from Evan's team
or whatever of course yeah but yeah I
mean that that is
whether I hire someone on team whether I
bring you guys on to help me with that
piece uh I mean there you've got you've
got basically a team of
people who are responding to comments
right and then looking for opportunities
and and then trying to promote
ultimately whatever the thing is that
they're trying to sell but in a
relationship-based way instead of just
cold Outreach to say hey buy my stuff
exactly and then they worked really well
right because I mean we're always going
through and I mean like this is the
biggest thing when when you ask someone
a question you get the wrong answer this
is what people ask marketers do all the
time oh that's not my client you get the
Dead Silence right people walk away and
like okay well that conversation we
always make sure we leave without you
being and that's the biggest thing right
how can you actually really drawing your
audience like for you when people are
asking questions your team are engaging
like no matter what it is hey you know
thanks for asking the question going
through love to be able to you know
here's a PD hey you have so much content
so many awesome things Evan like always
make sure you're leaving going hey love
to offer you a copy of my book you know
free you know free plus shipping right
like I'd love to hey check out this PDF
right I think it'd be and this allows
you to be able to go through and what
you're doing is creating more advocacy
because then an advocate is more
powerful than a client because an
advocate can bring you thousands of
clients if you actually treat them the
right way because they'll be your
biggest voice out there and that's what
we're trying to be able to do is raise
your not only raise your voice but the
people that love you and appreciate you
and also treat them with the respect
that they want to be able to see
and is at the core of your service of
what you do for people yeah 100 we're
here to be able to create Advocates
first and allow that bypro to become
clients how do you price that out
how do we want again it's all we have it
done for you right so we have an
evergreen that we just went through so I
was really blessed my my wife is
pregnant where I do with a baby girl in
October and so you know with that I
wanted to make sure I was out of the
company so we actually went through and
documented everything so we have an
evergreen program that exactly what we
do for our Elite clients to be able to
go through and teach every single person
how to be able to go through and build
the brand to be able to understand their
messaging their content how to leverage
Ai and then also how to be able to build
out this messaging sequence right to be
able to either for themselves or for
their teams and then for our clients
right that want us to be able to do it
for them they want to get there faster
we've got you know from our Elite side
where we go through we do everything
from Brand to content to you know
messaging cover the entire basis all the
way down to just to work your brand
where it's like hey look we're going to
help you be able to book your brand and
build your content but we're going to
coach you on the messaging so it ranges
anywhere from 3 500 a month to 7 500 a
month
great yeah really easy man I mean for us
we've worked with you know our clients
have products or services that range
anywhere from five to we've had one
client as a fifty thousand dollar
product right on monthly basis so like I
try and make sure that what we're doing
is helping the right people the people
that are adding value to this world not
just trying to monetize it and to be
able to help them Reach their ideal
audiences to be able to change this
world for a better place I love it man
all right before we got started you were
all jazzed about AI so so where is AI
with LinkedIn how do I suck on that and
you know how do I get better at it too
what you don't suck yet but what I would
actually hi Elise because it's it's so
new right like really was I'm jazzed
because again I was sitting down with
the LinkedIn product team on some of
their AI initiatives in New York here
about a couple weeks ago and what
they're doing is phenomenal right
they're really going through and being
intentional on it so some of the things
that I want people to pay attention to
is you know they have there's there's
this thing called collaborative articles
what they're doing Evan is they're
creating different tasks right they're
going okay this is marketing this is
branding this is this is YouTube right
being able to go through it and then
they're asking you and beings to be able
to go in there
and actually add their points of view
so I'll pull up LinkedIn here real quick
for everyone to see it and what they're
doing is they're indexing everyone right
and and based on how your fellow human
goes through and and engages on the
content
this is what's happening so let me show
everyone here this is one of their first
initiatives and they're putting a lot of
time and energy behind it so this is
LinkedIn creating AI content or creators
making AI content for LinkedIn they're
LinkedIn is creating the AI content so
okay here's the
um the main feed right here a
collaborative articles right being able
to go through we have marketing
Aggregates are going through
telecommunications I mean tons and tons
of information how do you recognize your
employees for their achievements right
so if I want to go in which I know I've
I've done on this one right here we have
725 likes 394 contributions right
going through I'm at the top I've got 77
people that voted that my content and my
ad to how do you recognize be specific
And Timely you can add your perspective
on each different one so what they're
doing is AI is creating this stuff right
here and then as human beings we're
going in and adding our thoughts and our
perspective to the article okay and so
what that does it allows you to be able
to get more visibility right being able
to get seen more as you see I make it
very interactive that's why a lot of my
stuff really gets seen and so what that
does right oh that's great that you're
adding you're getting more visibility
and you can actually become the expert
in the authority in your field because
now
when you go to my profile after I'm
doing this on a regular basis
LinkedIn is rewarding me and giving me
higher visibility right so
go to my profile
I'm a top marketing voice right because
I've been adding the contents to
LinkedIn I now
get different badges now I'm a top voice
and marketing entrepreneurship online
marketing social media leadership all
these I actually have
I now have the most badges out of
everyone on LinkedIn currently
so it allows me to be able to be seen
more and be found more for these
different topics that I have information
after doing 20 years in 16 different
companies I have a lot of information
right I'm able to be able to add a lot
of value and so this is one of the best
ways for people to be able to get seen
right not everyone get a top voice but
this allows you to get a top voice in
basically being able to actually add
your value to these collaborative
articles
and so that's one of the ways that
linkedin's using AI right now what
they're also using AI for is to be able
to get rid of fake followers bad content
you're going to start seeing them
leveraging AI for you know being able to
they're already using it for profile
builds and for creating your
um if your resumes as well too so
they're really integrating a lot but
that's what I want everyone to focus on
right now if I was going to push
everyone listening and you as well Evan
go through there like if somebody's
watching how would they go through
Linkedin to find these options what do
you think that your your topic that if
you want to add a device what would you
want to add advice on
uh say thought leadership all right
and so you can actually go through here
and of course it's
while we're doing it doesn't pop up so
let me just pull this up here real quick
well it's I mean whatever marketing it
doesn't matter they've got tons but I
mean like when you're looking at it now
it might just be not on a thought
leadership it might be under leadership
so when I'm going in here
and we'll actually type it in and
usually see leadership right here right
so now we have the page so they have all
these different pages that we'll go into
and now I can go to the leadership page
that's it and there's 1.7 million people
following this page so now you can kind
of go through and say oh do you have a
clear what's your strategy for
communicating your leadership Vision
right being able to actually go through
so this is how you actually find it
search for the title and topic but if
you go through them they're all these
different things I can type in marketing
the page will come up there's tons and
tons of these Pages the main page is
LinkedIn if they search LinkedIn skill
pages
this page will come up
and then that allows you to be able to
go in and see all the different ones
that they have Evan
got it so that's what I would tell
everyone to search LinkedIn skill pages
and then that'll allow that to be able
to come in and then what you want to be
able to do is start going in where can
you really add value can you go in here
to what's your strategy for
communicating your leadership and vision
and how do I add perspective all it is
is 750 characters we're not talking
about a huge post
right pretty quick pretty easy to be
able to do and be able to leverage that
and so this is one way that I would
seriously push everyone if you want to
start guessing visible on LinkedIn and
what linkedin's doing
girls actually start seeing them in the
next couple weeks the top voices that
are actually going through and adding
content linkedin's gonna start sending
an email out based on which which
hashtags and which categories you follow
and actually sending out to that those
audiences via email you're in the shirt
featuring everyone that's adding value
on a regular basis so now LinkedIn is
going to start helping you draw in more
followers and more connections awesome
yeah what are your thoughts on using on
using AI for Content creation whether
it's GPT whether it's swell people might
take an interview like this right and
they're like okay gbt like turn this
into a LinkedIn article or swell turn
into a LinkedIn article not like totally
made up of
give me uh you know a full article about
marketing that's not in anybody's voice
but in summarizing other pieces of
content turn it into written form look
you know our team we've got a pretty you
know heavy team of writers right and I
guarantee you we would have a lot more
if we didn't have ai I was very lucky to
be able to have friends of mine
um I'm friends with the guys that run
jasper.ai right they're here in Austin
Texas back when they were Jarvis right
before they get sued for my Marvel uh
but we've been leveraging and using that
and that's the biggest thing right you
want to be able to go through and make
sure they understand your voice guys
like you and I we've been doing this
long enough and creating content that I
can go in and say okay you are Joshua
beeley you are Evan Carmichael right and
it can actually pick up some of our
voice
AI is great to be able to do it to be
able to create the basis of my article
but if you don't have the emotional tie
a computer cannot generate that emotion
as human beings we make decisions
emotionally based on some degree of Love
or hate if we are indifferent to content
if we're going to differ to something
we're just wasting someone's time right
that's the one resource we don't get
back so like people are just putting out
content that's indifferent because
they're scared to be able to put
themselves forward so if you're going to
use AI to be able to create that content
help it to be able to do an outline like
I've got different prompts I was kind of
going through right
I've got actus Joshua bili a social
media Pro and Linkedin Authority create
a fun lighthearted article that explains
the benefits of using LinkedIn for X
right user expertise provide insights
and tips and language like if you're
going to use chat gbt to be able to do
this you better understand how to be
able to put all the different aspects in
and then go through and read it and
adjust it to be able to truly be in your
voice because this is the biggest
problem I think we're going to start
seeing Evan I think we're going to see a
used you'd shift right 2008 was big for
me I know you were in marketing back
then too like that's when everyone
started falling off right because the
people that were playing as marketing
and advertising companies started losing
money and they were gone right and the
rest of us were able to kind of stick
through the times you know 2008 2009 I
think we're in another situation now
where we're gonna see the the real human
beings that are not just leveraging AI
to generate a whole bunch of content but
to actually use it as a tool to be able
to create amazing content as a research
because if I got on this call and I was
like oh I'm a LinkedIn expert nice use
chat EBT to be able to do that like you
said right like they just use this video
and then made their own articles and
then you and I talked you'd know really
quickly that I was bsing I had no clue
what I'm talking about I think that's
what's gonna you're the one who sucks
Josh not me right yeah
so I I think AI is huge if you
understand how to use it so what we're
doing
is we're using this one tool and it's
actually working really well
um have you heard of the tool
um like you have to get Merlin
Merlin I know Merlin yeah so Berlin's
pretty good like one of the biggest ways
we've been able to really increase our
audience and be able to go through is
and it's one of the best ways on
LinkedIn is to be able to add insightful
information
on someone else's post so like if I want
to be able to you know if you're getting
a lot of visibility a lot of engagement
on LinkedIn I want to make sure that I'm
adding value to your content not just
going hey Evan great posts like cool
video right or if it's Ariana Huffington
right like I want to make sure I'm
adding value to her post so Merlin's a
great tool to be able to actually at
least help outline how you can actually
read the post and give you some Basics
and then going through to be able to
adjust it so you're making sure that
you're responding we go through not only
for myself but for our clients every
single day on LinkedIn I'm adding
anywhere from five to ten insightful
comments on other influencers content
that resonates with my audience
every single day what that's done is
I've been able to increase over 10 000
followers in less than a month by just
doing that right on a regular basis
and so this is what I want people to
understand right it's being able to go
through how can you be intentional how
can you use AI to be able to get you
there
but not replace you but to be able to
help give you a outline of what you
should be able to put on there and then
be able to really put your own knowledge
base back in there because most people I
love AI in this hit the button positive
reply or build a thought leader comment
and and linkedin's gonna be launching
that you're going to actually see
linkedin's already testing AI you know
being able to help someone create a post
using AI because they already have the
open AI integration
but it's not out yet and people go walk
was that just gonna everyone's just
gonna have a whole bunch of content that
they didn't create
and it's all about how you use the tool
not how the tool uses you I have a
notepad full of ideas here uh action
items it's scary
um but I appreciate all the insights and
we've got some work to do so if Josh
people want to find you learn more about
you dive deeper in your world obviously
I can find you on LinkedIn Joshua B Lee
but where else do you want them to go
that we can link up you know again I
mean I love when I get messages anyone
watching this right like and this is the
biggest thing Evan if you are going to
connect with me on LinkedIn send me I
want them to send me a personal message
why they listen to you why they love
your channel why they they follow you so
much because not only that helps me get
to understand them but it lets me build
a better relationship with you why
people love you so much but at the same
time too if someone wants to reach out
standout authority.com is our website
please check it out but I mean I'd
rather you rather everyone just come on
LinkedIn let's let's have a conversation
let's build a relationship appreciate
you man thank you for telling me where I
suck and uh taking the time no worries
man thank you so much okay okay so it's
been a few days since my one-on-one with
Josh and I thought I'd show you some of
the work that I'd done on my LinkedIn
profile but
we got a new head
new head highlights the benefit of
movement makers here instead of just
being a typical picture I've updated my
bio I help thought leaders get their
message out to the world my mission is
to solve the world some more problem go
literally themselves enough uh what else
have I done as we go down here just kept
that picture the same added some
featured links so these are the things
that I'm both selling and also some free
resources from The Mastermind to Movie
Makers to these two are paid this is
free the thought leadership success map
added some content and some articles so
this is the most recent one that I added
today and so it's a post that then leads
to an article which talks about stepping
into a bigger role scaling your business
so been adding daily content as per
these feedback and suggestion
and then anything else on here
I fixed the links here these were all
broken before when we did the one-on-one
uh added uh not just fixed all the links
there so those are all working out in my
high school in there
and I think that's a pretty good summary
so far of what I've done on my LinkedIn
page now to take it up a level Josh also
talked about the service that he
provided and I'm going to hire him and
his team it starts as a six month
minimum and have him do some Outreach
and I think this is key in that
investing in this can lead to sales and
it's not just about getting followers
and growing brand and that's a lot of
why I left linked in the first place as
I wasn't seeing any results and great
that you can get a few views on an
article but because it lead into any
results and so what Josh and his team
does is they'll also then reach out to
the people as he explained in our
one-on-one and talk to them get to know
them offer them opportunities and if
that leads to people joining The
Mastermind or joining Movie Makers then
that becomes a no-brainer to continue to
work with him and his team to help us
build this out and one of the things to
think most entrepreneurs go through is
when you get faced with the new
opportunities do you build or do you buy
it do you build it or do you buy it and
I could spend time building it I
understand how content works I could be
spending tons of time researching
LinkedIn content which hashtags how
often to post how to optimize my profile
it's all learnable it's all learnable do
I put somebody on it and train them up
and continue to build up my team and yes
it's all it's all possible or do you buy
and buying in this case would be buying
expertise happen to somebody come in and
not just give guidance on how to do it
but also actually do it and it just
becomes a matter of what's the best use
of time so the very beginning of a
business you build it because you can't
afford to buy it right like you put your
time effort hustle energy into the thing
that you think will yield the highest
results to help start you building your
brand getting customers getting Revenue
coming in so that you can afford to hire
people to come on your team as you
continue to build and scale unless
you're just passionate and curious and
you love it and and you do it because
you want to do it then it makes sense to
start looking towards buying so instead
of building it you buy it because your
time effort energy is better spent on
other things because it's limited
resource where you invest your time and
energy is limited and you have to focus
on the things that will move into the
most so I did my homework I didn't want
to just
disrespect Josh and not do any of the
work and say hey you just go do this so
tell me why I suck I did my homework and
going forward we're going to be engaging
Josh and his team so stay tuned and over
the next six months you can check out my
LinkedIn profile and content and tell me
if it's gotten any better to see my last
tell me why I suck episode with Devon
Ben to send the NBA mindset coach check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there the process of
anybody great it's like sometimes
initially we play not to lose right it's
like when you play not to lose you're
worried about making mistakes and then
you make more mistakes